[Music]
[Applause]
wasn't the fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm up in the holy [ __ ] man what a
great night to be here though sir back
in the place [ __ ] we are here as always
at the scum and villainy Cantina in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard in
[ __ ] Hollywood put your hands
together to the folks at home know that
you're real did you see me come in with
my Tom Cruise run I did I was [ __ ]
like Mission Impossible six [ __ ] fast
you also want the other side which I
thought was kind of classic right you
look like a 70s show can I be sure
absolutely sure in my heart the I did
something today who I met a [ __ ]
celebrity and I never do [ __ ] like this
I don't really name drop a lot but I
will [ __ ] name dropped this because
it was bad acid [ __ ] I got a text from
Jordan Jason's wife runs our company and
Jordan goes do you want to go over to
Disney at 9:40 and meet someone from the
Marvel Universe and I was like [ __ ] yes
like I'm already way I usually wake up
six seven o'clock start waking and bacon
so about 9:40 I'd be blissfully high
enough to beat anybody who do you got oh
my god and thankfully it was somebody
that liked being high helped to be
around because the conversation was very
minimal
I met goose today Wow the actual [ __ ]
goose man like and so George is like do
you want to go to Disney and take a
picture with goose and I'm like and this
is the weird thing
Jordan's mom is named goose that's her
nickname like that's what Jason calls
her so that's the goose in my world so I
was like why the [ __ ] would I go to
Disney and take a picture with your
mother like why don't we just do it in
her house and she's like no goose the
cat and I was like oh oh [ __ ] and I had
this moment of like I don't know do I
really want to [ __ ] drive like five
miles to take a photo with a kid
[ __ ] but then I was like [ __ ] it's
goose so so I said I said you know what
yeah man like I was about to get into
some sound [ __ ] on the movie I was like
this could wait a minute [ __ ] you know I
will totally go over there
and then in the background I heard like
on the other side of her phone go look
would you [ __ ] this be [ __ ] Jason
and I'm like why would I like she asked
me why are you yelling at me yell at
your wife and [ __ ] and she's like don't
start a fight with us and so he was like
come with me I'm sure like [ __ ] it if
they want me to take a picture I'm sure
they'd like Jay and Silent Bob to take a
picture and stuff like that and he was
like I thought you'd never ask
so he came over and we drove over the
hill to Disney and this was the this is
my favorite part of the morning you know
Disney lot for those who have never been
there and for those who don't live in
the area and have not seen the building
one of the buildings has the Seven
Dwarfs in it built into the structure
animation building yeah what is that the
animation but it's there giant like
built into the pillars like if society
collapses and [ __ ] like that and they
unearth these buildings like a thousand
years from now but be like they worship
to these little men like this was their
Supreme Court yeah this is their Easter
Island but so we pull up and mused I
guess has never [ __ ] been there
because we're going to the Frank Wells
building that's where they're doing the
the Captain Marvel event and stuff so we
pull up when we get to park in the front
and then Disney they got this like
courtyard where it's a bunch of plaques
with handprints of like Disney Legends
and icons and [ __ ] like that and they
got a sculpture of Mickey and Walt and
they got a sculpture of Roy and Minnie
and stuff like that that you could sit
next to and take a picture and I've seen
all these things he's never been there
so he gets out of the car he's like what
the [ __ ] like as if he was high and
[ __ ] he was like what the [ __ ] he's
like you got to take pictures I was like
where you gonna take a picture with a
very famous [ __ ] cat let's go do that
man
and he goes first this and so we went
into the courtyard and he stood in front
of the [ __ ]
dwarfs and took a picture but it was so
tiny I was like you come to the severe
foreground and I got the dwarfs in the
background you just come right up here
to the camera and he's like you never
stop [ __ ] directing and I was like
I'm trying to [ __ ] give you the shot
that you look for it [ __ ] and then he
goes you've got to line me up because
the way the dwarves are structured is
there's six of them and then on top is
dopey so he goes you got to line me up
over the top guy and I go what's the
[ __ ] top guy to you because to me the
top guy would be doc and he's like the
guy up top and I was like the dwarf up
top whose name you apparently don't
[ __ ] know I was like what kind of
[ __ ] I started first first time in my
life I was like maybe he's a Russian spy
like how do you know I was like it's
[ __ ] dopey and he goes like yeah I
know but what's his name and I said no
his name is [ __ ] dopey man and he
goes oh he didn't [ __ ] know the name
of dopey that makes him [ __ ] suspect
in my book yeah crazy suspect so we go
inside to the Frank Wells building and
[ __ ]
we find the event where you know they're
having like a media event I guess there
were some human beings there but they
only said you could meet the cat so Sam
Jackson doesn't want to say yes they're
like you're good enough for the cat it
felt like that Caddyshack moment where
he's like I got a pool in a pond pond be
good for you you know so we got in and
they gave us [ __ ] bags of swag right
away I was like this was worth the
[ __ ] ride over to hell man I got some
free [ __ ] like I put on power bands that
make noises and [ __ ] they gave me a copy
of the movie but I already bought that
and I said that to him I was like I
already bought it like we know you [ __ ]
it tweeted about it [ __ ] I was like
right on I think that's how I we're
watching you I guess I think that's why
they were like do you want to take a
picture with the Fleur c'n so they gave
us shirts as well and they're like do
you want to sure knows it go [ __ ] yeah
it's like if you have a bathroom I'll go
put the shirt on now cuz like I just had
a Stan Lee shirt on I felt that was
appropriate but this was very [ __ ]
[ __ ] goofs centric so I go I took the
shirt and I went into the bathroom to
[ __ ] change in the bathroom 40
seconds Jason walks in right behind me
also with the shade and I'm like we
can't [ __ ] both wear the free t-shirt
man in the photo and he's like we got it
so we [ __ ] went in looking like you
know DeVito Schwarzenegger twins
standing next to the cat and the cat was
awesome dude like the cat honestly was
worth the trip alone cuz he was so
[ __ ] sweet like some cats are really
indifferent like [ __ ] you but this cat
as soon as I came in I know what to go
for on the cat like I don't know
I don't want to brag but I know how to
treat a cat and [ __ ] so I went in right
for the [ __ ] spot and [ __ ] and he
leaned the [ __ ] into it and so they're
like shooting video and I was like oh my
God look at him leaning into this
[ __ ] pet man this is the first
[ __ ] Marvel Star I ever met did that
I met Chris Hemsworth he didn't lean
into my pet at all and she and they like
that very much
and then we sat there took picture with
him that we found out some factoids
about him he's 13 years old that's why
he's such a good cat cuz he's [ __ ]
like I'm on my way out he's incredibly
well behaved they put him on a spot on a
table and he didn't [ __ ] move even
though I was petting him he would do
that cat leaned into it where it almost
fell over but he wouldn't leave his spot
and [ __ ] and I bet he was high to
probably know the CBD kibbles right
there catnip that Nippon [ __ ] well what
they would do is periodically they would
stealth try to come in like there were
three ladies who were gooses handlers
and stuff and one would come in
periodically would be like oh good but
then I noticed that she was like palming
him a treat yeah so giving him a treat
on the sly and I caught her and I was
like you don't have to like I'm a grown
man like I you could tell me that goose
is well behaved because he takes a treat
not because he likes me or something
like that but yeah she was like you know
we gave him a treat just to keep him
chill and whatnot but he was so [ __ ]
well-behaved it was not so adorable I
grew up with a lot of cats we didn't
have dog
and then later in life when I got
married it flipped and it's all [ __ ]
dogs and no cats so it's been a long
time since I got up in some [ __ ] pun
intended but it was [ __ ] it was
really [ __ ] fun man we took a picture
and stuff it was kind of sweet very very
cool
I also went to a movie lot what today
where Universal ooh afford I went to the
theme park like any other [ __ ] person
could just do yeah my sister lives in
town from from Jersey Reserve and I want
to go to the theme park I said all right
if you want like I've been 98 [ __ ]
times but sure I'll go why that one um I
don't know
Harry Potter no she could give a [ __ ]
about Harry Potter she was just like I
think she didn't want to drive forever
to go to Disney and I'm glad because I
didn't want to pay for Disney because
that's no [ __ ] joke for like five
people yeah that is pricey right yeah
and so the highlight of my time was we
because if you've never been to the
Universal Hollywood it's basically a
series of escalators because they only
have but so much space up top and then
like there's the you gotta go on the
studio tour that's another escalator
down and back up to the lower lot where
there's now like two rides left there's
the mummy ride The Mummy into a roller
coaster and the Transformers ride the
jurassic park ride they're refurbishing
it's not going to be some world that did
not stop them however from not playing
that music throughout the park Bam Bam
Bam Bam
and so yeah everybody else wanted to go
on a roller coaster
I don't do roller coasters because I'm
that kind of [ __ ] so I'm like that's
cool I'll just wait here with my
daughter who also doesn't roller coaster
so which is kind of sitting there you
can't wander that much because you're 19
escalators away from civilization okay
so I'm trapped there for like an hour
and you know at first you know
[Music]
everything was better welcome to
Jurassic Park that's a great an hour
that [ __ ]
by the by like minute 53 I'm like the
top of my lungs it keeps going the same
[ __ ] cute it's also all [ __ ] no
orgasm
yeah what I'm saying like so it's like
getting jerked off for an hour real like
I get it man just give me that like slap
a little et on me man
yeah to the point were like bumblebee
walks over sucker you all right I lost
my damn mind
Thank You Universal that escalator man
were the 26 escalators that it takes to
get up and down I remember one time like
this early on is like 1995 I guess when
we were imposed on Mallrats Alphaville
was one of the producers on it Jim
Jack's nearly departed Jim Jack's
responsible for bringing you such movies
as dazed confused and tremors and
tombstone and The Mummy series The Mummy
that people liked and many other [ __ ]
movies also brought you mall rats so
their office Jim Jackson Sean Daniels
were set up at Universal so when we were
in post we were imposed here we were
posting at CBS Radford that's where the
movie was being cut by the editor Paul
the rest of the time we just hung out
with Jim at his offices on the lot and
Jim was making other movies so sometimes
would be like get out of here you guys
you just forget hanging out get out of
here go explore the lot so me and Mose
would jump in [ __ ] the go-karts like
the you know the golf carts and drive
all over got to drive like up behind the
tour up to psycho house and [ __ ] like
that
just had carte blanche [ __ ] driving
around I forgot why I started telling
the story I just went to the past I was
like what good times man before there
were 26 escalators yes beautiful thank
you so thank you that's important this
was so this was right in that Harris
during this time week because he was
working on a lot we had to run alot so
we can go to Universal like anytime we
wanted to go through the back door and
[ __ ] like that
it was awesome I was like life is always
gonna be like this and it never was like
that again so appreciate what it won't
you have when it happens because then
it's [ __ ] gone
so this is one during that era when we
could freely run in and out of the
universal theme park and [ __ ] no
[ __ ]
it's late at night man because we were
on the I'm the office and I was like
[ __ ] man let's go for it let's go for
the et ride cuz that was our favorite
like bad ride in the world I don't know
if it's gone right mommy took it over
and [ __ ]
for those that don't remember it was
like the height of Technology when when
they opened Universal like studios and
[ __ ] the tour but you know by the time
they closed it down it was not it was
just old and like the part of the thing
was you he'd go through it like there
was maquette setup and [ __ ] and woods so
the whole thing smells like pine-sol and
like when you went in you told people
your name and so like they wrote your
name into a card and then like swipe the
card gave it to you and [ __ ] then when
you got on like the bike cuz that was
the ride like it was you and a couple
other folks and [ __ ] you swipe your card
and [ __ ] as you get onto the bike and
you didn't understand what it was until
you got to the end of the ride
so then the bike takes off and it's you
know kind of like like a not nearly as
endearing version of the Peter Pan ride
at Disneyland
well you're just soaring above [ __ ] one
night and they take you through some
highlights of ET but then at the [ __ ]
end there's et and as everybody's coming
in for a landing on the bike the card
that you swiped was meant to make him
say your name as people left so he'd be
like bye mark
bye Kevin bye Susan
like it was that was the highlight
you're like all [ __ ] this
he's gonna say my name and was also the
height of Technology in its day
unbelievable so like by the time you
know we started hanging out there as 95
and most people stopped going to this
ride all together and [ __ ] so there was
no weight whatsoever and me and Mosier
would get in line and always give like
[ __ ] terrible names and [ __ ] like
[ __ ] and they're like [ __ ] like no
no COCC it's Swedish I swear and just
pray that et would be like bye [ __ ]
never [ __ ] happen man the technology
like didn't let it go and [ __ ] so it was
late at night we were like [ __ ] it let's
go right ET and should we run riot rody
- you made fun of it came out and had to
take the escalators all the way back up
to go where we were going as we're
coming up the escalators there's no
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ] dead right
there's nobody else there we thought we
were the only two in the park you come
up the one set there's a little landing
come up the other set it's the second
set me most come off landing the first
set we're [ __ ] and making fun of ET
turn around to people [ __ ] on that
estimate was the most magical thing I've
ever seen at a theme park in my life man
it was like I was it was so like I was
taken aback and they quickly [ __ ]
we're that were they like laying down a
flat-out bent the [ __ ] over man as it
was going on the side so if this is you
know how this is the railing on an
escalator stand here okay
[Applause]
this is the railing on the escalator
he's doing this and [ __ ] I don't have to
[ __ ] it and show you what [ __ ] looks
like no but I'm just got to remind you
that the bars curb they're doing this
while they're vertically ascending to
there I guess it would be their right
you know what I'm saying so that's a
skill test as this is going up and as we
rounded the corner and [ __ ] they must
heard our feet but they definitely heard
me go holy [ __ ] I'm a man like and the
tools of web bogging it were because of
the angle they went dashing up the
[ __ ] escalator as if we were gonna
chase him like hey what was that all
about
show us how that's done but I guess they
thought we were like park employees but
even if I was a park employee I would
have been like well done yeah holy [ __ ]
I never thought of this like [ __ ] who
thinks of that man who's like we're on
an escalator let's try to [ __ ] teenagers
definitely in their mid toys it looked
to be about our agent [ __ ] and I was
hoping that we run into him up top just
to be like you want to go to dinner I
just want to pick your brain amazing
Park yeah yeah my visit was not anything
like that there were a lot of wands
around but nothing was is that is that
did you go to the powder world pal yeah
I totally did did you buy one I did not
because my kids don't give a [ __ ] so I'm
not gonna like hold them hostage while I
go in like do I get a phoenix feather or
a unicorn hair you're the center of my
you don't get anything the wand chooses
the wizard man
precisely very geeky I did I did go to
the movies though where'd you see I
still got Zilla oh [ __ ] yes now by those
applause does that mean people also saw
it as well yeah a lot of people alright
let's do this way how many people did
not see Godzilla this week good I am one
of those folks and I do want to see it
how many people did see Godzilla this
weekend how many people were displeased
by Godzilla this weekend not much how
many people were pleased by Godzilla
this week go mark where are you I here's
the thing you always got to ruin the
curve listen
Godzilla Godzilla movies are basically
pornography in that all you were there
to see is Godzilla punch things in the
face and breathe blue fire at it very
true every other scene is [ __ ] to
get to the next scene yeah that's where
Godzilla blows fires the delivery guys
showing up and going hey did you order
this I know you need tennis lessons
great I happen to be a tennis pro are
you sure your husband's not coming home
I got you
sausage yeah like [ __ ] this bring out
Godzilla precisely so like the human
story is like fine it's as fine as it
has to be right to just literally keep
you invested enough to be oh [ __ ] Rodin
is gonna show up
[ __ ] yeah Rodin is showing up they all
show up don't they all show up is there
anybody show up that they didn't show on
the trailer what yeah yeah yes can I
guess yeah I mean there's there's some
monsters to show up at the end that are
not Toho monsters because they're like
not even named like it's in the front
credits like Rodin Dedra Mothra and
Godzilla appear courtesy of touhou
limited right who are the guys who made
the original Godzilla in like 1956 then
there's some other ones is like a
[ __ ] like spider creature and some
weird wooly mammoth
that like they don't even mention like
but we just made those [ __ ] things up
so wait I'm sorry Gamera doesn't show up
at all know what happened there they're
saving it he's from what he's what is it
a different company it wasn't Touhou
interested in I don't know no gods uki
well of course not
but in the world of Touhou his name was
Mia Suki that's right alright so wait
take me there how is it is it enough
fighting yeah you know and way better
than the first one because the first
Godzilla movie the Gareth Edwards one
that was where they were like oh let
them fight fighting in the garage it's
nothing but like it's blue ball on your
way through that movie they're just like
oh god yeah I remember taking my son at
the time was like nine years old we went
to go see Godzilla and he said you know
for a movie called Godzilla you thought
there'd be more Godzilla in it and I
said yeah that's true
this one plenty of Godzilla they put
made they make up for it far more than
guns they'll make up for it but they
also it feels like the more you add the
mythology onto it the less interesting
it gets so what's their mythology the
new mythology is that these titles
protect us these Titans protect earth
and we happen to be like a parasite
that's infecting earth which is why the
Titans are rising do get rid of us and
so we should let them fight because I
guess self-loathing humans what why does
it I saw in the trailer like [ __ ] goes
south like something bad happens it's
most of the world there's a
post-apocalyptic world there's it our
world I mean he gets there I mean
somebody has a hate on for [ __ ]
Boston because they destroy Boston like
nobody's [ __ ] business
spoilers like it's the one city they
haven't killed yet so I'm like that's
gonna [ __ ] Boston really hate that
[ __ ] town cuz it's like Massholes
you got no place to park your car now
[ __ ] how many fights here let me ask
you this ask me this how many are
anybody friends yes there's a king of
the monsters which is
Zillah yes there's also a queen of the
monsters which is Mothra they've that
who said that the movie at some point if
they're now they're gonna [ __ ] and have
a baby well it's more like they are they
are kind of the mated pair but they
don't thought but it's like Mothra is
there like a good wife to support her
husband when he dies at of atomic fire
and so she just kind of like breathes
out pheromones yeah there's a whole
weird gender dynamic thing there there's
that too she sacrifices herself for
Godzilla because again [ __ ] spoilers
man I'm sorry
she says also my ass was this camera in
it [ __ ] yeah listen like I had a blast
goes it's fun to sing it's fun to see
because if she won't see this in 40 X
one should see this in as many DX's as
they can for is the top then go to four
but like I I was a Godzilla kid I grew
up watching Godzilla movies on you know
back in the East Coast I need to find
thirty movie on WPIX or Fox 5 like
either one I think the 4:30 movie for me
was on channel said did you ever see the
fourth every movie did you have that you
know we had the New York feed that is
amazing [ __ ] feature on every day
Mondays to Fridays on channel 7 which
was ABC affiliate and it was called the
4:30 movie and it started at 4:30 and it
ended at 6 o'clock when the news began
this before they invented the 5 o'clock
news so 6 o'clock the news again so from
4:30 to 6:00 o'clock you watched an
entire feature however there were
commercial breaks so if you think about
it 4:30 to 6:00 it's about 22 minutes of
commercials almost it's almost you've
taken a movie down to nearly an hour and
they didn't really do part 1 and part 2
so like they would do themed weeks so
like you know they would do Planet of
the Apes week where they did all five
Planet of the Apes movies one after
another
but each one incredibly short so much so
that when I bought the laserdisc set
from Japan of like a Planet of the Apes
all the [ __ ] movies letter box before
Fox put it out years ago I sat down to
watch it was like right on now I'm gonna
see in its proper aspect ratio and the
movie begins and they're on a [ __ ]
spaceship which never happened in the
fourth or a movie burger so I was a
goddamn it the Japanese got the better
version of this [ __ ] movie man and
there's this whole scene where he's
talking about like are we the modern day
Adam are we all gonna [ __ ] this baby
into space like it's a crazy opening
secrets but that's part of the movie
proper but to me it wasn't for most of
my life I knew a much shorter version of
that movie I gotta be honest with you
the 4:30 movie version was better it
moves really does so they would do
themed weeks and one they did of course
was monster week which would be Godzilla
destroy all monsters mecha godzilla
mecha godzilla vs. Mechagodzilla did
they throw a King Kong into that one
sometimes so if they had the you know
never the [ __ ] King Kong that we knew
and never the black-and-white not the 77
King Kong because then happening at that
point and certainly not the
black-and-white one but maybe the Toho
version yeah like if they had a tow a
license they would run those flicks so
that's how I knew those those films and
then later on
Walter Flanagan the guy from comic book
men he that's his religion like Toho is
his [ __ ] faith and in you know
Mallrats we talked about going to the
dirt mall and like [ __ ] Rene yells at
him about Godzilla bootlegs and [ __ ]
that that there was a big part of our
existence where like Toho started making
movies again pre-internet
and like the suits we're still [ __ ]
suits but the detail looked much better
it was still the same spirit of the
original Toho big rubber monsters detail
got much better but you couldn't get him
here his pre-internet so it couldn't be
like oh it was no way to find him unless
he went
- like the dirt mom went to bootleg Stan
and found somebody who's like trading
Godzilla bootlegs from overseas and [ __ ]
so we would spend a lot of time going to
like remote places looking for Godzilla
bootlegs and once we found them he would
take him home and [ __ ] like it would
be a religious ceremony
pretty incredible so I knew he was
looking very forward to this I do want
to check in with him and be like did you
see it
he liked the last one but he was like
you know my problem those movies are too
many [ __ ] humans he's like I don't
need a word of dialogue I just want to
see all of them fighting [ __ ] I will say
there was one Godzilla movie that made
the human story totally riveting it was
Shin Godzilla Godzilla resurgence I
think was the title when it came here
but it was basically about these
Japanese salary men this one guy worked
in like the 98th level of bureaucracy
the Japanese government who knew that
[ __ ] Godzilla was coming but and
nobody would believe him like it's about
the failure of the system to recognize
danger and the success of the system to
protect itself in all costs and so it's
ultimately about how you know human
interference in its own preservation is
its own doom right and it's it's it's
harrowing like you and I mentioned it
online that that and Chernobyl are kind
of the same story and then it's like
radioactive disaster because men are and
women and the government is unwilling to
do the things it needs to do to protect
itself and in fact the barnacle enough
systems and red tape and bureaucracy is
what's keeping us from saving ourselves
it's fascinating
again it's it becomes a movie that's
sociologically interesting which is what
Godzilla always was yeah it's true is it
wasn't just like rubber suits and [ __ ]
it was always about like we have created
a monster with the atomic bomb yeah like
the only country to ever be victim to
nuclear annihilation making a movie
about nuclear annihilation in the shape
of a giant monster like it's fascinating
looking at it that way well then get
[ __ ] silly because he's got this kid
who can barely boast smoke rings but at
one point stop picking on [ __ ] menya
man
I really got it in for him and [ __ ] I
wonder that's that's kind of oddly
fascinating so are we meant to be is
America meant to be Godzilla in the
allegory the creator of Godzilla so yeah
that was always kind of mentioned in the
background yeah you know and also it's a
movie like I remember again showing it
to the same kid who went at nine to God
sounds like what's [ __ ] Godzilla I
showed him the first one just before
that and I had never noticed how much
that story works because it's you're
feeling bad for Godzilla cause he
doesn't want to be doing any of this
like my son was just like oh he doesn't
want to destroy Tokyo he doesn't want to
step on that building he just can't get
he's in a place he doesn't want to be he
just doesn't he just wants to go home
like he's the kid who broke the lamp and
didn't know he broke the lamp yes I
didn't but it's it was just there and I
was playing the game and I broke the I'm
sorry fault though I didn't mean to
crush all of Tokyo I'm just giant my bad
is you did it that way it's kind of a
sci-fi version of Nutty Professor a
little bit it's a bit that it's a bit
Frankenstein and it's it's it's a kid
story at the end of the day but yeah I
would go if you'd if you did Godzilla go
see king of the monsters like it
scratches all those witches you wanted
to scratch and the human story is the
best [ __ ] actors in the world to do
some of this dumbass so they gotta like
veer a farm ago they go Chandler they
got a witch a theme they got O'Shea
Jackson jr. they got Anthony Ramos from
Hamilton they got like they went soup to
nuts and like let's get really good
people to say these dumbass [ __ ]
lines and they got 11 right and he got
11 by the ground who emotes very well I
did not see that but you know what I
watched I caught up on season 1 of and
then also watch season 2 went through
him very fast there's only a few of them
but my god they're [ __ ] fantastic
it's outside genre but really well done
you see fleabag yet no I've heard it's
amazing
oh my god it's [ __ ] astounding like
invest the time it's like you know it's
I can't say it's like daringly original
because we've seen things that are
similar particularly like there's a
trope or that she uses about turning to
the camera to address it or acknowledge
it and stuff but it's so breathtakingly
honest and and like funny as [ __ ] and
heartbreaking like my it's like it seems
like it was made for me my favorite [ __ ]
in the world there's [ __ ] they can make
you laugh and then instantly like rip
your heart out as well and this
absolutely did it and it was six
episodes like a half-hour piece what is
that five hours or 10 hours total mean
yeah it was it was quick it was it was a
quick in-and-out my math is terrible
obviously but you're totally worth your
time man particularly like as a writer I
think you really dig it I
I was so [ __ ] pleased with the time I
put into it really again like I didn't
want to take anything away by saying
it's not like I'm not saying it's not
original it it takes like a familiar
trope and puts an incredibly original
spin on it a fresh take on it and her
performance the lady who created the
show is also Phoebe Waller bridge oh my
god she was the voice I guess I can link
it to our world she was in solo she was
the robot and solo becomes the
Millennium Falcon she is fantastic
like just spellbinding as a lead man
I've enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it it's a
story about a woman in London I mean
that's the best I can do for it
but it's [ __ ] riveting really
well-done storytelling you know what I
was impressed by what Swamp Thing you
watched it I did it was one thing no
[ __ ] you coming this bored not worth
swampland I didn't even know is
available how did you cover this boring
then what's one thing it dropped
yeah the first episode dropped they
don't wanna design yeah one on one a
week how is it it's pretty good it's
pretty good
I mean there there's a certain amount of
suspense that you lose if you're a nerd
and you know that
minute Alec Holland shows up you're like
oh you in danger girl yeah look Oh match
it's gonna happen to you man you just
wait so wait don't start off with a
Swamp Thing it starts off with [ __ ] in
the swamp doing stuff like you know
vines and tentacles and all that [ __ ]
but you do not see the the swampthing
creature from the jump is it told them
flashback or they don't have a Swamp
Thing yet there is one thing yet Alec
spoilers if you don't know the story of
swamp yes
spoilers Alec Holland is the the human
being who will eventually become kinda
yeah the Swamp Thing the intelligence
his intelligence will inform the Swamp
Thing depending on which version sounds
like they're doing Alan Moore it feels
like it yeah so does he does the
explosion happen by the end of episode
one spoilers yes good that's a good way
to end it I mean that's if you know
Swamp Thing at all like that you don't
get to go further in the story until
Alec Holland goes screaming on fire and
I thought there's a world where they
could have dragged it out a little bit
more because it opens with like a br
cane he's working for the CDC's trailer
that was like oh yeah use some weird
[ __ ] happening in the swamp and people
are getting sick and it's an illness
nobody could recognize and then there's
some corporation that's doing testing in
the in the swamp and they're like
dropping modules of this weird viral
thing that's causing the swamp to over
metastasize and and there's a maid she
runs it down the column he's like I know
some [ __ ] too and then like oh we should
know some [ __ ] together right right this
be great maybe we can like have a drink
together and be a whole thing I just got
to go collect the sample from the swamp
sorry I we told you spoilers no Linda
Holland I'm not that we've seen okay
nothing we've seen but it's that makes
it cleaner yeah but it's a super deep in
body horror like it's all about like
[ __ ] you know vines and twigs and all
that [ __ ] like working into bodies and
like exploding [ __ ] from the inside out
alright it's it is way better than I
expected it to be it was directed by
Len Wiseman Lenny Wiseman the I who
directed me at one point in live free or
die and he did sleepy Hollow's that the
name did that yeah for a while yeah he
did of course most famous for underworld
series was his and he created it and
stuff so he did he do every episode or
just I don't know my guess is he only
did the pilot because he's one of those
guys you bring in as a director and a
pilot to make sure that pilot goes right
so yeah I don't know who else is doing
them but it's really well done I'm
[ __ ] in is it a full hour or like 42
minutes I'm full our real hour yeah and
it looks great because I understand they
built a giant swamp on a set in in North
Carolina like they took an entire
soundstage and they just made it a dive
tank so that you had it like five feet
deep and everything is [ __ ] swamp so
when when they're doing that stuff you
can control the lighting you control
where the cameras are you don't have to
deal with nature as it is yeah [ __ ]
you don't really want to be in a swamp
means nothing a real swamp and [ __ ] no
it's really good I'm in who's playing
Alec Colin anybody does there anybody in
the cache you recognized the only people
I recognized were were Virginia Madsen
and will Patton who play the names
escape me but they're like the the old
moneyed people in this town that have it
in for a be arcane is there a wood drew
Jason wood room not in the pilot unless
it is an I missed it Jason Woodrow
spoilers becomes the floor on ik man hmm
I look forward to this show man I'm glad
you told me that it's on I can't wait to
watch I'm gonna go watch it when I get
home and shoot it that's it now my
head's not gonna be in the show because
I'm gonna be like I want to watch Swamp
Thing speaking of seeing a thing yeah I
think we see GOG I seen a thing
last week Derek Mears who actually plays
the man in the suit was at your show he
was here here last week he snuck out
early yeah yes one thing was here we
just didn't know yeah
speaking of Swamp things there is
himself owner of the bar
and Jaycee give it up for him one look
around this place could tell you that JC
is a fan of science fiction and all that
goes along with it and in that wonderful
giant world of sci-fi the Star Wars
franchise of course is included and the
biggest news in the Star Wars franchise
at the moment of course is galaxy's edge
the new theme park that they just opened
down the road in Anaheim at Disneyland
is the biggest expansion they've ever
done in Disneyland what is it a hundred
and fourteen acres
14 acres or some [ __ ] [ __ ] massive
114 something like that math not
required for this show I have not gone
you I have not gone either
which I'm questioning why the [ __ ] I
haven't gone so I got to get my ass in
gear and go my my cousin emelie just
went this week so I got to ask her about
it but someone we know [ __ ] went of
course JC went and so JC's got a report
man tell us about galaxy's edge walk us
through it this so we I went Friday
which was the first public day you could
go and we got a hotel reservation at the
Disneyland hotel for the night before
cuz that guaranteed you entry the hotel
was seven hundred dollars for that night
just for that night yeah so people who
really wanted they knew what they were
doing and I got to go in it I'll go to
galaxy's edge they're gonna put you the
poverties edge man whoa you do is seven
hundred dollar hotel room 130 dollars
take it to the park and then I got the
only thing I question yes when you buy a
ticket to Disneyland does that get you
into galaxies yes yes but the first
three or four weeks you have to have a
reservation in addition as preview this
yeah out of town but typically it'll get
you in so really so in the future
if I'm going to Disneyland I buy a
ticket that means I also get to go to
galaxies and yes I could get my fat ass
through the doors and [ __ ] like that
because it's packed it's it wasn't bad
when I was there because they've limited
the amount of people who can go in to
the preview time so it's comfortable so
did you get to do the entire world I did
a lot of it I did the Millennium Falcon
ride which things to a peace puppies
where's the entry the entry that we went
through is kind of by Splash Mountain
through like the frontier territory I
remember when they were build in there
yeah but when you get in the it's almost
like an inflated version of cars land we
when you get in the walls and the
mountains and everything are so high you
cannot see Disney you can't see Anaheim
buildings it is you're in just
completely immersive completely
immersive except for all the people
wearing star wars t-shirt standing
around you all right but just don't look
at each other and just pretend but it's
very cool ever all of the employee and
the only thing that ruins Star Wars Star
Wars but the employees it's wild because
the employees all pretend like they're
villagers on this planet bought to so
everyone's in character everyone's in
character and so if you go up and ask
them something they treat you like a
tourist like well I don't know of what
happens on your planet where what planet
are you from but um but - we have three
sons you know so we have three sunsets
so that's the way they speak to you do
they like two more suns in the sky for
you
I don't [ __ ] [ __ ] rock three suns
that's like that's impressive so it's uh
it's pretty it's very immersive again if
you can ignore all of the other out
world tours so the story then is like
where everyone who goes is a visitor
from another world yes and so it's very
neat all of the shops are built into
this little bizarre market that looks a
lot like I don't know like something you
would see in the Mandalorians show or
like most ESPA from Episode one like
done up more I'm busier the Millennium
Falcon ride we you go in and you go
through like a hangar ish and you come
into a little mission debriefing do you
go up the ramp you don't go up the ramp
you had one job Disney I'll tell you
what though coming around and this is
something isn't it did you hear that
disappointment they just lost about five
hundred dollars if I was them I'd get
the [ __ ] on that somebody's not gonna
Tesla you uh you come in you turn the
corner and you see the Millennium Falcon
a life-sized Millennium Falcon park
there I know you've seen that in real
life which to be fair like I saw the
guts of a Millennium Falcon and the
outside looked like a movie said and
then separately oh the inside an
exterior piece of the Falcon but I never
saw like a life-size exterior and
interiors
I'm pretty jaded I've I've done a lot of
Star Wars and coming around that corner
I was you can't help but like the hair
on the back of your neck stands up the
guy I was with felt the music
it marks the God so look in Trump's Ron
Williams just whatever it sags a couple
kids [ __ ] on an escalator there was
no you know the rest of Disney plays
music throughout it when I was that
there was no music playing in bar two
but what they did is every 5-10 minutes
they have surround sound speakers all
over the tops of the buildings yeah and
they'd have like an x-wing flyby sudhir
like and you would it's so realistic you
would even watch the cast members be
like well they're acting genuine you
well you I asked I said like do you ever
are you well you are you faking it
they're like no we just haven't gotten
used to it yet like it's that real
sounding and I did so the Millennium
Falcon oven they don't put like a little
one across the pocket on string yeah but
it sounds so real and then the
Millennium Falcon you kind of get your
mission to briefing Han I believe is
already gone so I think this is post
episode 7 so so right and so chewy talks
to you in Hondo who's the pirate from
Star Wars Clone Wars talks to you and he
sends you out on a mission to I don't
know Steel Co axiom I guess and are they
doing the solo story and you are you on
the Kessel run no but you get I guess it
changes so there's different missions
you can go on and the better you do on
the missions the longer the ride goes or
it impacts where you go and at the end
of the ride based on how well your team
did you get credits so you get like we
got like 6,000 credits or something and
that will download into your phone so
when you're playing the game in the park
those credits can go to buy like virtual
your software to help hack into the
Imperial computer so even if you don't
actually ever go on a ride ride there
there's like a game built into all of
the facades of the park that's kind of
insidious which is really cool
the falcon ride when you get through the
debriefing you walk into the holding
area is the holding area the Falcon with
the chess board and the the bunk and the
whole thing and it's they just like let
you walk around in there which is crazy
because I've been to Star Wars
Celebration and the fans build their
version of it but this was like probably
a third bigger and it is I mean I just I
was like oh this could be my bedroom
like if I was single forever this would
be my bedroom it's so cool you would be
single forever if that was your bedroom
and then you walk through the hallway
from that room down the hallway into the
cockpit so other multiple cockpits there
are multiple cockpit do you see that
like people going you know their own
doors so you only see you only see your
own that's kind of immersive and there's
six people so there's a pilot a co-pilot
two Gunners and two engineers and it's
like again it's like Star Tours if the
controls you had move actually you could
move where you go you were actually in
control so the the pilot controls left
and right on the ship the copilot which
is what I was goes up and down and does
that are you in a car that then goes yes
it actually moves the projection changes
with how you go holy [ __ ] so then you've
got the two Gunners and the two
engineers that like every time you crash
they have to like hit buttons to make it
work like to bring the Falcon back and
are they all facing forward everybody's
facing forward so I think their controls
are like off to the side like as it
wraps around the cockpit
I was the copilot and I'm trying to go
up and down but what gets really cool is
like a third of the way through the
thing
you get to reach up and pull the lever
and go to Oh
which I don't care who you are it just
that's worth the $700 Hotel say that
before it was incredible
I did the I didn't do but my I went in
with my friend who did the $200 light
saber experience which you guys were
talking about the Harry Potter wand yeah
this is like that times a hundred and it
costs $200 $200
there was a four-hour line to get in
$200 per person you can do fourteen
people at a time and when you're in
there each person in Harry Potter it's
like they pick a cute kid and they're
like we're going to find your wand now
adults go buy all these wands in the
lightsaber thing everybody who pays gets
a little lightsaber building station and
so you can do you can do 14 per 20
minutes so you can do what 42 people per
hour at $200 is eighty four hundred
dollars per hour Disney's open for 12
hours
they're doing a hundred thousand dollars
a day in lightsabers my biggest adorable
that you did the math on that oh my god
I'm sitting there I'm like how do they
afford all of this I can't even put two
bartenders on on Fatman beyond and then
I start doing the math on the because
I'm not building the labor stations and
I'm like oh my god that's how a hundred
thousand dollars in lights save
ourselves only so the wand chooses the
wizard but the lightsaber chooses the
wallet what do you walk do you walk out
you walk out with a lightsaber if you
guys have seen people posting Facebook
photos they look kind of like plastic
and cheap but it's all steel like you
can you could kill somebody by grabbing
the handle like well that's a [ __ ]
reason to go right there
you can buy a lightsaber that will kill
somebody that's all we ever wanted
but it's very very cool like this is
gonna be very nerdy sounding this is the
place to say if I didn't have multiple
lightsabers at home already
totally would be worth it you know what
else did you see
did you see the coke bottles and
different shape coke bottles are very
cool and if you look like I went to Ron
tow Roasters and I got some nuna beef
nuna jerky which is major chords I wish
it was made of pork so noonas ours a
little like an episode one they're the
things that like Jabba the Hutt bites
the head off and shoots at the gong and
I guess according to lore they're not
supposed to taste very good and I got
nuna jerky and it does not taste very
good it's like chewing on tree bark for
seven dollars and fifty cents one ounce
I wonder if they were like supposed to
taste good and they named him something
else and like these things like [ __ ]
it's in Canada [ __ ] feature not a bug
call it
but beyond the coats on what do you
think it's made of it's Turkey but it's
just not good it is not good don't get
it we took spoiled Turkey and call it
space the the the drink dispenser where
they pour the coke all of that is in
theme - so the coke logo isn't on it it
has like the or bash coke logo and the
7up is all different it's all they like
they can you tell by the logo like
that's the coke logo but in the imperial
language yeah you can basically tell
what it is and they've got fun little
Easter eggs all over like if again I'm
exposing myself if you can read the
Orbis language they have like little
like nods everywhere like in the
lightsaber room I found one where you
get the crystals for the lightsaber it
says thx 1-1 3-8
which is kind of fun so the castles are
the Khaybar crystals yes can you read
this language I can that was what I got
yeah
[Applause]
was the story behind the stories yeah I
mean to be fair useless not when you own
this ball very [ __ ] [ __ ] trade
right people walk in with their name
badges and it's just like oh hello
Elizabeth and people were like how do
you know my name and I'm like I use the
Force and they're like no really how do
you know my name creep like you have it
on your PIN and I'm not there like you
can read that and I was like yes and
they're like okay creep creep did you
get to go to their Cantina I did go to
their Cantina and super spot ahead
it's very cool yes uh I spend a lot of
time in this Cantina and it it's it's
amazing but it's a weird mix for me
because I feel very hot like this is
very homey yes and that feels somewhere
between like a bar and a theme park so
it kind of hits this like middle ground
where like they're like hey two drink
minimum to drink maximum 45 minutes
you're on the clock what do you want no
you don't know okay you go over here
okay what do you want like it was very
like I guess they got it right how many
they only got one of them this place
only one of them and there's booths kind
of around the edge like this but there
are no bar stools anywhere because they
don't want people sitting down and so is
the tables high so if you go into those
tables you can sit at the otherwise it's
all bar that you have to stand at and
then like they have a drink rail like
behind the bar that another wave of
people can stand at they do have some
fun drinks though the drinks were pretty
good they have one called a fuzzy
tauntaun that when you drink it it makes
your lips and your tongue numb which is
crazy I have no idea how they did it
it doesn't sound appealing but it's
interesting chemically to be sure do
they taste like some random dude
cut his arm off every like half an hour
I do not but Rex the old pilot of Star
Tours yeah who got booted is now a DJ at
the cantina oh I know you're gonna say
he's drunk at the bar I'm out of work
they are damn aliens they have a $75
beer flight that they want a $75 one for
beers like beer tastings for $75 that
they bring out in a on a wood board that
has rank or teeth in it and they fill
the rank or teeth with with the beer
doesn't make it taste like $75 I didn't
I could not you get to take that cup but
you get to take it home worth it and
it's so good and it's not like cheap
plastic it's all like poly stone like
like if you've got a real Tiki mug so
that's very cool it's it's awesome it's
very cool but like I'm not going to be
driving an hour to Anaheim to spend a
hundred and forty dollars to go and buy
drinks at that bar and that's a mirror
in the park and show you but yeah it's
it's very did they have a blue milk they
have blue milk in the park that is
different than the blue milk in the bar
and it's it's a lot like ours but not
boozy it's like pineapple and coconut
and things like that like Star Wars
butter beer yes the blue milk is pretty
good I did not try the green milk but
I've heard you don't agree milk that
came from the nipples and well yeah yeah
they sell that yes do you get to milk
the thing yourself
like Luke Skywalker did be like you do
not make an angry face that's in club
turn on you you got to be a member of
club 30 to be able to do that to work
the nipples it's very cool to like the
little shops I was I think my
expectations were very high they're like
we have a creature shop here and I went
into the creature shop I'm like I want
to buy a life-size like salacious crumb
or whatever like if they sell that it's
all I was like because I'm a 38 year old
with disposable income I was like I'm
gonna go buy this $400 salacious crumb
thing and it's not for us it's for
people who have kids and they're like
$15 and little and rubber so I'm like
yeah that's really cool if I was 12 but
at 38 I was like I want the real thing
like it doesn't there's no such thing as
slave girl usually at 12 that's when
you're like I want the real thing and by
38 you realize there is no such thing
but you've reversed the process yes what
kind of merch they saw this I seen a
picture at one point of wooden
stormtroopers do they sell those they
have like a wooden stormtrooper wooden
c-3po is able to look like they're not
they were made but almost like the one
from rogue one
yeah it's that's very cool they sell the
de Jarek board at the toy shop so they
have like The Creature Shop the toy shop
the Wardrobe charge shop as well they
have a droid shop but that is like the
lightsaber and I didn't get into that so
you pay like a bunch of money 150 bucks
yeah and you get to build your own droid
but they then you can buy a backpack and
they like will interact with other
droids like if you buy droid and I buy a
droid like they'll talk to each other so
we don't even have to be friends our
droid will be friends robots can be
friends the shops are pretty neat like
but you can buy very good-looking Jedi
robes but you can't wear them there why
because then you might be confused this
is a cast member and then a kid goes up
and it's like mr. qui-gon can I get my
photo with you and you've been at the
cantina too long any
like screw off kid you really [ __ ]
thought this through man they're like
this where Disney falls apart and I like
that you think that that's the worst
case scenario is somebody's a screw off
kid
and Natalie won't touch my lightsaber
it's neat though like they don't have
photo ops with the characters like it
Disneyland you just walk around and like
there's Chip and Dale and you take your
photo at galaxy's edge like we saw kylo
Ren walking around with stormtroopers
but he's like on a mission and so like
if you're like can I take my photo with
you this is arm troopers well like yell
at you and it'll be like I don't have
time for this puny or a puny outworlder
and he'll like storm by or he'll like if
we're trying to get a selfie with like
the imperial shuttle thing he'll be like
you know he'll come through and stop it
is the Imperial shuttle there it's
sudden I heard it's not kylo ren's
fighter I heard it was oh maybe I
shouldn't show I'm gonna share it anyway
I heard it was a a ship that they
designed for Colin Trevorrow
Episode nine that didn't get used and
then they just like well let's put it in
galaxies it really so
but it's cool I mean it fits they have
an x-wing in there but life-sized x-wing
do they do they ever play the stores
music or no no the only music they play
is in the cantina they play the and the
guy who was sitting at the booth with me
which obviously I get defensive he's
like why don't they have the damn band
in here why is the band not in here
which is something I hear here nightly
and so I like it really people call it I
feel like wow why don't you have the
band yeah where's the band and so I'll
say so I said to him I like just gets me
going I was like well I mean we are in
Episode seven and eight era and the jazz
band was very 70s I was like now it's
all about DJ so they got DJ reksai here
he's like the Stevie
oki of the Star Wars universe so they
seem to accept that the band is no
longer cool and it's all about DJs when
you get to seven eight and nine so it's
like a douche bag is version of Star
Wars just a dick for like 12 hours it's
yes I guess okay now what else can they
see what's the what in that what's the
high-end merchandise you could buy I
didn't get into that room it was an hour
way buddy r2d2 that's very expensive
they have a real r2d2 they've got I saw
somebody posting on Facebook that you
can buy the yoda lamp that like r2d2
tries to steal and Empire Strikes Back
what that little light the little light
yeah mm-hmm I want that for $1,000 I
never know how much I wanted that until
he just told me I could buy that so you
could buy a droid at the droid shop and
then buy the lamp and then have the
droid steal the lamp and you're like and
reenact like Luke they're building now
there's one that they're gonna open in
Florida they haven't opened one there
yet but the one they open in Florida is
supposed to also have a what why you
hate Florida so I mean other than a nine
other reasons you should hate Florida
yeah yeah yeah
we're not here to we're not here to
lower things we're here to raise I gave
up that well you know you why now that
theme park is gonna be like this theme
park but instead they're also gonna have
a resort part to it where if you're in
the hotel there are no windows all the
windows are video screens that just show
[ __ ] space and fights and [ __ ] and it
won't be this [ __ ] where you look around
you're like oh that [ __ ]
wearing an Avengers t-shirt I'm out of
the [ __ ] game and [ __ ] everyone who
comes in has to wear these clothing like
the so it's the completely immersive
experience my friend
our dad sounds [ __ ] amazing I bumped
into my friend amazing or tyrannical
like we built a prison for you that you
can't even see the outside world where
these [ __ ] clothes speak this dumbass
language that nobody will speak in the
rest of the world and they'll Bend all
your [ __ ] money yeah sign me up yeah
like sounds like a dream if that's
prison I'm in I like it when they're
that direct about it as well one of my
friends is was on the team that came up
with all this story for galaxy's edge
and he was like this is really cool he
wanted to be there opening day and see
people's faces and he was like just wait
until you see Florida like the hotel in
Florida just if you don't have to see
actual Florida then I guess that's it I
mean Orlando is in really actual Florida
it's true true
the rest is so much worse so your
recommendation galaxy's edge I would say
well also I think at the end of August
there's the ride the flight of the
resistance ride which is 28 minutes long
and I guess it's for different rights
like you get on a ride and you get it
like some sort of storyline and you have
to get off the ride and you go through
like a tunnel or some theme thing and
then you get on another ride that takes
you to another ride that takes you to
another there's this this will be yeah
at galaxy's edge at the end of the
summer it's not open yet so that's
there's another there's another ride
coming in but I would say it was very
cool when it wasn't overcrowded yeah I
would say we're like wait till a Tuesday
in September when kids are in school the
new ride is out everybody here is an
adult just play hooky from work I'm sick
show up at Tuesday at 8 a.m. and go
through the whole thing because it is I
mean it's as close as you will ever get
to being in Star Wars now the [ __ ] a
commercial for it right there man I mean
you can't put it better than that there
it is man when do you think you're gonna
go
I'm thinking about some Tuesday in
September that sounds about right to me
sounds like the tip and also we couldn't
even go if we wanted to right you got to
have reservation reservations until June
24 and then it opens to the general
public I'm probably waiting till the
fall now if you could believe that [ __ ]
unless like you know I make a phone call
and be like hey I make a calls like hey
keV called you he's got a friend it's
awesome everybody should go is very very
neat I'm up to get like a third job to
pay for my one trip to galaxy's edge
I'll do it but well you need a
lightsaber a droid $7.00 jerky yeah it's
like the only day without the hotel
excellent
there it is give it up for Jason his
review of God's bad well done Gavin all
right we got some show to do we got some
news to talk about some news mr. mark
barnard is an old news sound ladies and
gentlemen but he's so good at [ __ ]
sniffing out news we sent him loose on
the internet and he pulls up the news
that others found for us give it up for
mark barnard need found some news in the
news given the news this is pretty cool
and it's cool because it almost never
happens and it should happen way more
often ava duvernay is making a new god's
film yes from rumors - yeah she has
brought on a co-writer to help her write
the script and that co-writer is Tom
King who wrote the miracle of the mr.
miracle book with the Batman writer the
Batman writer she got an actual comic
book writer to help her write her comic
book and he did work out mr. mergo
something or two about the new gods and
I think they're leaning heavily on that
mr. miracle big Barda relationship
that's in that book so she was like well
why the [ __ ] would I go anyplace else
when I could go to the guy who did this
really well not that long ago and so
they are co-writing the script together
which I think
[ __ ] awesome really sweet man that's
awesome and nice to bring comics talent
into the world too and smart to be
laughs I bet you he knows more about
these characters than I do you know call
like because again comic book writers
live with these characters we can we got
they've written these characters more
than anybody will ever write these
characters they've gone down all the
[ __ ] cul de sacs they did with no
story they're they've made all the
mistakes and learn from them
and even if you're being totally
mercenary by hiring the comic book guy
to be your co-writer that gives you
protection when the Nerds come for you
if you don't do the right things like
yes I get I got the guy what else who
said supposed to do I get the guy who
does this [ __ ] March got an alibi now
she's got an alibi it was him he did
that he needed the thing that's good did
they give any sort of date when this is
happening no they haven't dated yet
because they're still DC is at the point
where they don't have to start like
cherry picking release dates the way
Marvel used to have to write where it
said we got this plan we need it out in
May we needed out of November because we
got to build seven movies down the road
to do this thing
DC seems to be a little bit more not
like from the hip because that's the
wrong word but they can do it when
they're ready to do it like they don't
have to satisfy some release date math
to make it works like we'll make New
Gods when we're ready to make new guts
if he takes his year to do the script
it'll take us two year to do the script
and then we'll get there we'll be ready
so there's no date yet for release
speaking of no day before released I
know this is completely unrelated but
before I forget you see on the internet
this week that picture of Scarlett
Johansson dressed as Black Widow with
red hair from a long time ago they are
making Black Widow right now yeah in
that [ __ ] up like they didn't announce
we're in production they're just quietly
off shooting a black widow movie the
[ __ ] snakes never told us nothing all
of a sudden they're like in Norway or
some [ __ ] it's underway now she got red
hair so that's certainly not the one
from endgame it looks like it's a movie
set in the past but we were just talking
about Latin last week like what are they
doing next yeah there's one of them
right there yep exciting his [ __ ] very
exciting
speaking of Marvel and the Russos which
we weren't but sure they just signed on
to
adapt magically gathering yes when I saw
that just when you thought like that
couldn't get any more mainstream like
yeah that game has really traveled deep
into the culture and now it's gonna go
even deeper once it's on Netflix my god
the exposure that they'll have that's
crazy and there with to the best
storytellers of our time did you ever
were you ever a Magic the Gathering
player uh-huh just somebody that made
fun of it a lot no I didn't play it we
sold it at the secret stash back in the
early days of the secret session so it
was always kind of fascinated by it
mmm i D&D was my fix in that realm I
never did the card thing uh-huh
I had a bunch of friends who did and
swore by it but I too was like but I got
dice man that's all I need to buy I
don't need like 19 shoeboxes filled with
cards I'm gonna save that for well now
you're [ __ ] sorry you didn't get 19
shoeboxes full I am very finger to be on
the goddamn pulse yeah there there looks
like that's their first post endgame
commitment no I mean other than their
big studio like they've got a studio
thing they're doing right yeah Markus
and McFeely we're going to work at yeah
Agbo is there their big studio they got
something like 300 million dollars in
credit so they can be their own actual
studio and finance [ __ ] and the only
other TV they've done so far is dead the
class for Syfy right the Russos produced
oh that's true yes and I did that
screening I hosted the screening yeah
but this will be animated this will be
on Netflix they similarly don't have a
date for it because animation can take
forever
but yeah that's super cool very cool
good for them good for people that like
magic and [ __ ] and where's it gonna be
on Netflix the Netflix is Jesus you know
everything don't they well for though
the next few months they have everything
yeah I mean I think you're gonna start
to hear a lot of Netflix acquisitions
and productions and announcements
because they are looking down the pike
towards 2020 maybe even the end of 2019
when Disney Plus starts and all the
Disney [ __ ] dissipation Netflix it's
true and then when Warner Brothers
starts their streaming network all
the Warner Brothers [ __ ] will disappear
from Netflix and then Universal will
have a streaming network and the
Paramount will I guess and then Netflix
will be faced with a landscape in which
they can't license anything anymore
aside from some of the smaller things as
always gonna be Lionsgate she's always
gonna be you know the sort of like in
Soleri studios but the big ones are all
gonna be on their own homes so they have
to produce all they've got to create
their own IP their own stuff of their
own to sell yeah which is what goes
behind them signing like filmmakers and
TV producers to like massive overall
deals like hey Mark Moore bring us
everything you've ever done we will
happily be in the Mark Millar Universe
business [ __ ] I got a universe I'll sell
them cheap not desperate enough man
nobody called me out from Netflix so I'm
sure they're not desperate enough you'll
know that they're [ __ ] desperate when
they're like you got any ideas yeah true
north trilogy click yeah
there's a rumor that a Keanu Reeves will
be in the Eternals that's kind of cool
it would be dope it's all we got
but I heard that rumor as well that'd be
cool I also heard a version in the rumor
where he wasn't in the Eternals that
they were thinking about him for dr.
doom which I was like that would be
[ __ ] amazing man I'll be honest with
you I'm on board with the Eternals movie
but it didn't get my blood pumping when
they first announced it that being said
when they first announced guardians the
galaxy I was like what are their their
[ __ ] minds why would anybody then I
saw it and was like oh so I ain't gonna
judge prejudge Eternals but it's
definitely not something that I was like
holy [ __ ] I'm definitely more excited
for master of come through blushing I'll
go anywhere that they want to take us
and so if Kevin Feige and Coe think that
there's an interesting enough story in
the journals to tell that me as a Marvel
fans going to appreciate that it has
some connect ability to the stories
they've been telling thus far I'm in
I'll take it
speaking of connectability yes Quentin
Tarantino apparently wants to make an
adaptation for the screen of his Django
Zorro comic book he did it at Django
Zorro Kyle did for dynamite Wow yeah so
he hired Jerrod Carmichael from the dark
Carmichael show stand-up comedian actor
to co-write the screenplay for Django
Zorro cut wait co-write the screenplay
mm-hmm did he write a comic book script
yeah Matt Wagner did it Matt Wagner did
the comic book Quentin wrote the outline
and Matt Wagner wrote the script where
the [ __ ] if I Ben how did I not know
this
I love Matt Wagner how many years ago
Wow so what he's saying that like he'd
be happy to see them do a cinematic
version he's not going to do it himself
now he's producing it and co-writing the
screenplay with Jarrod Carmichael
that's [ __ ] hot yeah which reminded
me so much of Blazing Saddles in a weird
way in that Mel Brooks wanted to make a
movie about a black sheriff it was like
you know what I don't know anything
about Mel Brooks said to himself black
people so he got he got Richard Pryor
Richard Pryor co-wrote Blazing Saddles
with him and was going to star until he
not quite blew himself up yet but like
had probably his first beginnings of
problems with drugs and couldn't get
insured which is which is how you get a
different guy a sheriff Bart Cleveland
little indeed so the idea that a film
producer knowing he wants to make this
kind of thing was like you know find me
a black comedian to come and get at this
and make it funny make it pop on the
screen help me out help me out you're my
only hope
Jerrod Carmichael smart when can we
expect this that is another thing that
is like Quentin is committed to it but
there is no yet date for it it's just
it's been announced as a thing that
looks like could happen interest which
is kind of cool because I'm all about
worlds colliding and if you give me as
or a movie that also has Django in it
[ __ ] yes
I'm in what else you got that's it
brother you're out of news that's it for
the week how about moon night something
happening with moon night do you know
something about moon night who said it's
out there the interweb this isn't just
you going like I want him there I mean
we all do but did you hear something
like they've talked about perhaps that's
about to happen really I haven't heard
anything about it
me neither venom and spider-man 3 I've
heard that that Sony's interested in
pushing that narrative for the next
spider-man movie to include venom and
cross him over I mean look you [ __ ]
certainly proved he's got an audience am
I correct yeah so you know and I'm not
necessarily against that ID before it
I also saw an image of Wonder Woman 80
for the licensing show is going on in
town right now not it not here in Vegas
licensing show is apparently you go
there and it's like every license that's
available for purchase and pushing and
stuff like that so like you know
coca-cola has a stand and you could go
licensed coca-cola put it on a shirt
make an action figure
whatever [ __ ] Pez my [ __ ] peeps all
the pee candies and one of the things
that's there is Wonder Woman 84 and
there's a poster of Wonder Woman 84
that's up and the suit that she's
wearing looks a lot more like the Lynda
Carter
Wonder Woman outfit so I saw the picture
the colors are much more vibrant they're
not they're saying that are not treating
looks like a sequel it's just a
completely different era of her life but
it's some of the first artwork that's
been out there in the world the logo
looked very [ __ ] cool but her outfit
was noticeably more colorful more 80s
for lack of a better description so that
looked very very exciting I hope they
come up with an in story reason for her
to have to twirl around to change into a
suit
I'll care what it is I just want
spinning wonder women they're not done
you should pitch that alright alright so
that's all the news we got that's all
the music ladies and gentlemen man [ __ ]
it mark found you the news is give it up
for mark guitar now
now we arrived at the second part of our
show which is third part tonight really
actually it's the third part of our show
always we come to the other part of the
show ladies and gentlemen the part where
we turn it over to you the audience the
Q&A part we've got prizes to give away
as always what we do is ask JC to pick
three out of the audience you asked a
question
it's got to be question that both mark
and I can answer and stuff something
that can create a little bit
conversation if your question is deemed
worthy enough you're gonna win a couple
of cool prizes here man you're gonna win
this sweet-ass poster commemorating
tonight's a show of fat man Beyond by
our very own at Nate Gonzalez over there
this poster is signed by me and mark and
Nate and so three people who win are
going to get in one of those if you want
one of these and you don't win one of
these you can find Nate after the show
he's usually over there by the bar with
Dark Knight Returns on the internet dark
navy turns out what is the web's dark
Nate returns at big Big Cartel calm
that's for the home viewers but a lot of
people always see the artwork a little
worker we buy those posters they're
those the other winner the other thing
that folks are gonna win of course
thanks to our good friend deacon and our
good friends at 4dx
our two tickets to the 40 x cinema
experience you can redeem these here in
town down at la la la live if you've not
seen a movie in 40 X that chair comes to
life and practically [ __ ] you I can't
give you a better a better advertisement
for this than that it's an astounding
experience which I imagine if you want
to see Godzilla in just me you'd be
shaken to the point of just you'd come
that's how they'd shake up so much so
it's definitely worth checking out if
it's playing there so you're gonna win a
poster you're gonna win a pair of
tickets of 4dx at this point we turn it
over to JC to pick some folks from the
audience
picking some winners before we go
anywhere else though this says please
sign the back of these two sticker
sheets and give away the rest and these
stickers are [ __ ] adorable oh look
it's stickers of me and Mark for family
and beyond who did this you did this
come here real quick
come right here what's what's your name
young shaver turn around tell Bama
miles Ritchie miles this is gorgeous why
did you do this it looks expensive he
paid for it you paid for it right the
[ __ ] on man so we get to give these out
everybody at the end of the night as you
head out man there's two piles make sure
he takes the stickers Baba
great [ __ ] job man thank you thank
you may give it up a mouth that's
awesome
he brought stuff okay what's your name
young shaver my name is Greg Greg Greg
Greg thank you thank you
first of all I've been following your
career for quite a while both of you
guys thank God
I really appreciate actually being here
my my unique situation kind of lends
itself to here I'm if technically I'm a
filmmaker but a writer I started off
when I came out here and I happen to
work in the industry for a little bit my
me and my co-writer Lee Anthony wrote a
movie called war which that Lee and
Jason Statham eventually so eventually
though when we wanted to we had an idea
to pitch which was a I grew up on the
universal monster movies you know
Dracula Frankenstein The Wolfman
and I'm also a big film noir buff and so
the idea was you know and of course one
of my favorite classic comedies was that
in Costello Meet Frankenstein so he
thought this would be kind of cool to be
able to mix the genre together and kind
of pitch a film noir
monster movie and shot entirely in
black-and-white well the thing is nobody
in the studio's that we will try to shop
at or even our agents or a manager at
the time didn't want to have anything to
do with it because nobody wanted to do
anything that was period nobody wanted
to do anything that was black and white
and the name of the movies called noir
and nobody wanted to have you know the
name on top of what they didn't want to
do so eventually we end up deciding to
go almost on our own because they were
trying to classify us as just
screenwriters but we love movies we
wanted to be filmmakers and we just
decided it's about time that we start
doing that and yes so we kind of just
kind of walked away to do our own thing
so anyway I was listening to something
you were saying a while back about
finding your own voice and just doing
the things that you you love to do I put
on the table on the movie we're in our
third inning go go Noir and and we
wanted to also tell long-form
storytelling you know that's kind of
exactly there it is so it's noir the
film and it's IndieGoGo which will end
on June 14 and we have a cool trailer
that's up but my question of both you
guys is we screened the film at our
studio and it's a longer form
storytelling that kind of they don't do
anymore because a lot of things are cut
cut everything is about shortening get
you in and out and but once we are the
group that we send it to have taken a
look at it once it got to the end they
kind of really liked it a lot and what I
want to ask you guys is that but most
people keep saying nobody wants to see a
long two two and a half hours almost
three-hour movie sure and ensure
insurance so we tried to take scenes
out but it didn't feel right it felt
better with everything that we had so
was there a moment for you guys mark if
something that you've written that you
just you'd that voice in your heads just
felt like it's right and Kevin even when
you're editing was there a moment where
people are telling you one thing but
your gut is actually telling you
something else how do you how do you
block out the noise and listen to that
I'll go first just because I'm a just at
the end of editing the flick so I went
through something like that my instincts
are always to make it as short as
possible
so I'm for me it's you know I learned a
long time ago that like I'm all rats
first cut of the movie we had was 2
hours and 15 minutes it was 1995 and I
was like comedy could work in 2 hours
and 15 minutes you know and we had a
test creating it did not [ __ ] work at
all so I learned pretty early on like
[ __ ] especially if you're trying to
make things funny which I guess this
speaks more to that like some things
deserve to be [ __ ] long comedy always
deserves to be tight on reboot I got it
to a cut length and at first cut and
announced what it was and then was like
you know and now I'm gonna take it down
further and then I got hit with a bunch
of like don't [ __ ] touch it like why
would you cut it we want to see every
[ __ ] second of it which I understand
the logic of it who's going to see this
but [ __ ] fans so they would love to
see as much of it as possible but
ultimately for me I got to serve the
story and the story tells you what it
needs to be even if there's things you
[ __ ] love in it the story always lets
me know this can go this can go it
reveals itself and nobody asked me to
keep cutting this movie but every time I
watched it I was like you know what that
line doesn't need to be here this is how
I went about it and this is just talking
about the editing and I'll try to get
back on back back on track with your
question but I remember when I went to
see like movies where I'm like oh [ __ ]
this is it this is it like I'll use an
example but I didn't use that while I
was cutting when I was watching the last
episode of Game of Thrones every two
four minutes or something
I kept got checking and checking the
time going this is the very last episode
of Game of Thrones are they sure they
want to do this like are they sure they
want to say this line like they don't
get to do this again next week the
beauty of that show or any show is like
while it's up and running you got
another chance to bite people back if
you lose them on some [ __ ] one episode
but this was it so I've looked at movies
like that to where I'm like this is it
this is like like Justice League went
through that filter for me and and I'm
not here to put it down but when I
watched it every step of the way I kept
going like this is this is like the
first time they made a Justice League
movie and they thought that line counted
like so and again I'd [ __ ] on it
that's that's just how I viewed it
through that process and took it into my
own work so what I've done is I cut the
movie and I've played at the house all
the time people come over and watch it
sometimes they'll sit in the back and
watch it with them but what I've taken
to do lately is sitting down one floor
where I can't see the movie at all and
all I can do is hear it and hear the
audience and so I ask myself with every
single [ __ ] line you haven't made a
view askew movie in [ __ ] 12 years or
more like since clerks - so 13 years so
there are gonna be people hitting seats
on this judging it harshly going like he
hasn't made a Jay and Silent Bob movie
in 18 [ __ ] years that's how he's
gonna start it this is what he's going
to do so as I go through it as it plays
I just keep listening and put it through
that filter and still wind up with shift
to cut where I'm like you know what
I waited [ __ ] this many years to do
this movie that line doesn't make it
that don't count out it [ __ ] goes so
that's my process but that should still
apply to you I let the thing tell me how
long it should be if you feel the thing
should be what it should be
there's your answer you know and I'm
saying now that comes with a cost
right like it'll be a bunch of people
going [ __ ] man that's long or [ __ ] can
you do it shorter or [ __ ] but if that's
what you feel it is that's what it is
now that's what you feel it is in script
form as well right like you haven't shot
the thing yeah that'll be a different
experience to once you get it it's way
easy right now to be like this bugger
needs to be three hours long once you
got all the footage and see it then
you're like now you know what we can get
out of here a lot [ __ ] quicker
oh yeah no we've shot the script for him
it's already a Shabbos oh we've already
shot it and the movie is so the movie
come clocks in probably around 250 240
250 and you feel it's all [ __ ]
inherent for one year we edit edit and
then we kept bringing group of people in
after a time we've taken scenes out some
scenes stayed out but then scenes put
back in because you know story wise I
just feel like so many times people have
to assume that a movie has to be two
under two hours and that should apply to
everything and was ironic is when
Avengers came out came out was three
hours long then you know I could go and
say hey Avengers of course people come
back and say whoa you're not the
Avengers like their recipe was we're
gonna [ __ ] make people want this for
10 [ __ ] years right so that by the
time we get to our last episode they
probably weren't thinking at the
beginning I hope we end with a
three-hour movie right but they knew by
the time they got there they're like
[ __ ] it's three hours but they're like
you know what they'll watch every
[ __ ] second of it because they want
every second of it and I think that's
been the struggle it's been five years
in the making we're this close to
finishing up this year but there is them
there's that moment when your brain
you're like trying to figure out am I
sure
but every time I see that's like I love
this movie I love the length of the film
that for me died on the sword of what
you feel it is one of two things is
going to happen it's all upside the way
I see it number one if you're right bang
you were right number two if you're
wrong you're gonna learn that you were
wrong and that's an insanely valuable
so go with the [ __ ] gut on on this
one but then if it doesn't pan out the
way you want that's the the lesson is
perhaps long is not the forum you know
what I'm saying but either way you're
following your gut and the result you
have no control over anyway
right period so since you have no
control over the result why not make the
one that you're happy with so at the end
of the day even if everyone hates it
nobody sees it you [ __ ] love it you
know what I'm saying like I couldn't
guarantee pleasing one member of the
audience and that's you might as well go
for it
and then probably you know but if
there's a lesson to be learned you will
learn it and if there's a reward to be
reaped you're gonna reap it so I say go
with your instinct story telling you to
be that it wants to be that honoureth I
will I will differ a little bit in that
I agree that the story will tell you
what it wants to be the story will as
you make it as you edit it as you test
it as you show it to people the more you
live with it the more it will reveal
itself to you but there is also in the
waste and where the Kevin said you know
comedies are short they almost always
are like it's all about timing it's all
about pace it's all about rhythm and
it's all about getting to the next laugh
as soon as you can get to the next laugh
and and there are no two and a half hour
long comedies there just aren't they
don't work that way there is there is a
mode that genre requires to a certain
degree that there's deviations from it
sure there are three hour westerns most
westerns are not three hours because
it's pulp it's adventure it's like get
me in shoot some [ __ ] find the girls
kill the bad guy get me out everybody
wins there's ways to embellish that
there's ways to enhance that and elevate
that but the the genre is what it is
noir began as pulp it began as like a
detective [ __ ] it began as horror stuff
it began as Jean rrah and John Remora
and the nut is asking for propulsion
it's asking for acceleration it's asking
for momentum and that kind of momentum
also embellishes and
and feels like it asks to be fast right
like it asks for a certain amount of
pace and independent of seeing your
movie and your movie might be fantastic
but ask yourself how many three hour
long war movies you see and the answer
is probably not very many and that's not
to say that every one of those in two
hours and 45 minutes isn't brilliant and
isn't wonderful and isn't having worth
produced but the marketplace often
dictates the kind of thing that it wants
I one of my favorite movies of all time
is aliens it is literally like to me a
perfect movie and I and the version I'm
most familiar with is the theatrical
release because that's the one the first
came on VHS that's the first one that
you know when you inhale that movie and
cable and in the world that's what you
see and then you get like the director's
cut which has like another 40 minutes in
it and I love the director's cut but I
understand why they cut everything that
I cut out of the director's cut like I
like having it I like having the turrets
in the hallways I like having you know
the the first look here's a domestic
scene I'm Hadley soap and here's the
kidneys here's why noot is so good at
making her way through the tunnels but
you don't need it like the movie is
brilliant without it I like having it
but I don't need it and I think it's
when you get to that point in your movie
where you're staring down the barrel of
to 45 to 50 it becomes merciless it
becomes kill your darlings it becomes I
love this scene does it get me to the
next scene in such a way that I have to
have it and if there's a way to make it
but I don't have to have it then it
becomes am i fighting for a thing simply
because I love it or because the movies
ask it for it and I think if the answer
is the movies asking for it you leave it
if it's because you love it then that's
not to me enough of a reason to keep it
and I've first drafts of everything that
I've ever written have been too long
like 15 pages and it becomes a process
of just merciless and looking at
everything and saying does this earn the
time that it's on the page well let's
earn the time it's on the stage you know
does it move better leaner and the
answer is almost always yes and then
there's a point where you say I can't
anymore because now it's the heart of
what it is and that that point is always
a it's a moveable feast for every for
every storyteller and you just have to
figure out for yourself
does it need it or do I love it and love
isn't always the best defense for
leaving it in there helps to throw it up
in front of people to like honestly like
if you get it to the place where you're
like this is the movie and then get it
in front of 50 people I will be more
than happy to invite you guys to come to
our studio at Qwest and actually get a
perfect screening of it because I would
value your you hungry with bodies though
we don't need to be just the two of us
yeah get 50 people in there cuz you get
50 different opinions right and you also
more importantly you'll hear the room
while it's planned mm-hmm that's that's
always a big factor and stuff I and
mine's comedy so it really doesn't have
as much relevance but there was
something in the Brody section of Jay
and Silent Bob reboot that I absolutely
loved and swore would be there into the
final cut where he talked about his
daughter because it's a joke I've always
wanted to make his name was Brody Bruce
so he named his daughter banner Bruce
and so he it had been around since I
wanted to do Mallrats too so I included
like a good one-page dialogue bit were
Brody went into his life like you know
when Jay and Silent Bob encounter him
and reboot he's at this at his store and
we did like a one-minute kind of update
on his world and I [ __ ] loved it but
just because I loved it wasn't enough to
keep it like it was a kind of aside from
the main story the story is the boys and
we got a thrust forward and get to the
mission and [ __ ] so I had to let it go
and I kept it in as long as I [ __ ]
could until the point where nobody asked
me to take it out but I just realized
this is such a diversion it creates far
more questions than it [ __ ]
entertains or anything like that and
while we head into the real pertinent
information in a minute and a half
people are still going to be stuck on
some new [ __ ] that I just threw in there
because I really loved
and that doesn't serve the story so put
it up in front of people absolutely
thank you get I would love to get a
picture with you guys at some point yes
but first you get a [ __ ] poster two
tickets man well done got that pleasure
Thank You JC we got another victim as
they say as a lady what's your name if
not no what's your name everyone give it
up for Tessa she also doesn't like
Florida so yeah oh you're the anti
Florida lady yes so you guys usually
film over every Tuesday
my birthday is exactly a week from today
you were not filming on the 11th so I'm
here today my question is I will turn 29
next Tuesday happy birthday week in a
bit thank you and my it it's kind of a
two-part question one is what is
something you're really happy you
accomplished before 30 and what is you
wish you accomplished by 30 because this
birthday even as a millennial we're all
hitting things a little bit later
marriage children buying houses paying
off our student loans I mean never be
able to buy a house you tell me but I
feel like 29 it's hitting me you're just
gonna roll right over that that's a real
big issue anyway back to you sorry it's
your question I have a decent full-time
job I work for the government I work for
child support so if you hate me I'm
sorry but I mean it's hitting me a
little harder it's my last year in my
20s and I feel like what do you are
super glad that you accomplished by then
and what do you wish you accomplished by
30 just so I kind of know what to
experience from I mean this [ __ ]
he may was at Sundance before he was 30
I know and I don't want to say like the
older generation but I know you're a
little bit
than me so like what are you happy that
you accomplished and what do you wish
you would have accomplished I am very
happy as mark kind of reference that
like all that my career started when I
was technically 23 yeah was I yeah I was
23 and I was Sunday instead of 94 so I'd
be 24 at the end of that year so yeah I
was 23 years old and it might it was not
just my career as a [ __ ] dream come
true and each movie led to the next and
stuff so naturally I'm very happy that
happen in my twenties because like what
would I've been doing in my 20s if that
wasn't going on that shaped most of my
life I was having a discussion with
somebody the other day where I was
talking about how it's kind of I don't
regret it and I'm not like this isn't
bittersweet or anything but I only lived
like about 23 years of a normal
existence and then it's been 25 years of
this existence and and we were talking
about the early movies like why clerks
and mall rats and chasing amy and Dogma
hit hard and worked very well I was like
because they were made by a real person
that was made by a real live boy who had
thoughts and feelings and some of that
[ __ ] was like close to things he did he
worked at a convenience store he did go
to the mall he was in a relationship
with a girl like kind of like jay-z
gaming he was Catholic he never met her
[ __ ] monster but he was a altar boy that
came from real life the moment clerks
happens it gets picked up by Mira Maggs
I stopped living a real life and start
living a dream life make believe where
it's just like who you want to make
pretend let's do it until you're [ __ ]
dead and so that's that's unrealistic
and from that can only come artifice so
from now until the end of time anything
I do is not going to be as authentic as
everything I did in the beginning and
those movies are informed by 23 years of
a normal existence you know and and then
I stopped leading a normal existence and
so the fifth movie is what it's a movie
about making movies because that's what
I do at that point that's all I [ __ ]
know so you know I I'm glad i made those
movies when i did
and not because like you know I started
my career at an early age that was
[ __ ] nice but that was when everything
was urgent that was when I was unhappy
and not like constantly unhappy and [ __ ]
like that but I was Restless maybe
unhappy is not the word Restless that
was you know that was when I was at a
place where I wasn't peaceful in life
and not not peaceful meaning like I beat
people up and [ __ ] but like there was a
yearning I was a Bruce Springsteen song
come to life I got to get the [ __ ] out
of here but I didn't want to really
leave I just wanted to start my [ __ ]
life and say something in blah blah blah
so I got to say something and I said it
all in a fury right away one after the
[ __ ] other and [ __ ] and then all of a
sudden I ran out of [ __ ] to say because
I ran out of real life I exhausted
everything everything that I didn't
jested for 23 years went into clerks
Mallrats chasing Amy and Dogma so by the
time you get to Jay and Silent Bob
strike back it's literally a guy going I
made four movies I'm gonna talk about
him in the fifth you know cuz I've ran
out of [ __ ] real life [ __ ] to say now
some people like why can't you do
another chasing Amy
that's because chasing Amy came from a
painful place that was not a happy
person that made that happy people don't
necessarily make great art it's just
that simple I'm in a much happier place
so when people are like make another
chasing Amy
essentially that's saying rip your life
apart tear your heart apart go back to
misery go back to that hurtful feeling
go back to like not knowing if you were
gonna [ __ ] like and this is just being
dramatic but like wanting to go to sleep
and never [ __ ] wake up because your
heart was torn asunder
that's where chasing Amy comes from and
that's why people connect to it because
people always feel that at a certain
point but I felt anything like that
in [ __ ] 20 years in order for me to
make a chasing Amy I probably have to
get divorced my wife would have to be
like I'm [ __ ] through with you and
[ __ ] then I'd have some pain and then
I'd have some [ __ ] to express but I
don't really have something that meaty
to offer you because [ __ ] really worked
out for me so what am I supposed to say
you know what I'm saying what am I
supposed to say that most people can
relate to on the level that they related
to my first four films so that's where I
have to actually change and become a
filmmaker in the first four films I was
more of a vlogger or a blogger as a
[ __ ] filmmaker I wasn't making [ __ ]
up
I just took from my real life then I ran
out of real life and then at a certain
point I started making [ __ ] up
you know that's how you get to like tusk
and yoga hosers and people don't really
like my sense of imagination whatsoever
they liked when I used to steal from
real life and stuff so it's tough to
explain to people like how it works and
the path of like your life as an artist
and what you ingested before it all
began and [ __ ] like that but that's I'm
glad that [ __ ] happened in my 20s like
if if the best work that came out of me
happened in my 20s I'm glad because that
represents the boy that started this
journey the kid that sat there in his
bedroom in New Jersey behind a counter
in a convenience store and dreamed of
this that's what he wanted more than
anything else and he sacrificed his life
and his heart and everything he felt and
his relationship like chasing amy was
like you don't we don't get to make that
movie unless we sacrifice our
relationship on the altar of making that
[ __ ] movie like that kid was willing
to like give it all for art to say what
he needed to [ __ ] say and because he
did he was rewarded with a life that
doesn't allow him to say that kind of
[ __ ] anymore it's kind of bittersweet I
guess but the money makes it easy so I I
feel like I'm glad it happened then
because I was at my most authentic then
that was the realist version of me now
you all get a diluted version of
entertainer somebody who turns on a
version of Kevin Smith to go out and
it's still very much me but at the same
time it's heightened go back and watch
like the evening with Kevin Smith I'm
not the person I am today I've talked
very much down here and I'm not really
thinking about delivery or anything like
that and then the older I get the more
I'm like well people paid money to be
here you better be entertaining move
your hands a lot and [ __ ] like that so
I'm glad that happened in my 20s the
other thing I'll throw in some glad I
had a
by the time I was 29 because my kid is
now about to turn 20 this month and I'm
not like a decrepit old man hanging out
with my kid like I the other day I was
driving around with my kid she was
driving the car and tree like that and I
was [ __ ] plugging in my ipod and
playing songs and [ __ ] we were
relating and [ __ ] and it wasn't like you
know take me to the senior citizens
palace you know it was like I felt I
wasn't gonna say like I felt young but I
felt like like oh I got to enjoy her
while I'm still relatively young before
I hit you know true middle age or I
guess I am at middle age I don't know
have a kid young that's what I I know
it's not real fashionable and chicks
ever wants to play and [ __ ] around but
like it worked out like I'm glad that I
had a kid at 29 you okay so the thing
I'm most proud of stuff before 30 and
the thing that I regret not having done
before 30 okay same story when I was 19
years old I was a junior in college
there was a writing for television
competition at st. John's University
where I went and to enter this thing you
had to write a pilot episode of a TV
show that was on the air that you loved
and you sent it to Hollywood or
sponsored by Paramount and Ubu
production sit Ubu sit
oh my god good good dog and I'm like
[ __ ] it I had the only show that I watch
on TV is Star Trek The Next Generation
so I'm gonna write a Star Trek episode
because why would I [ __ ] not I don't
know any other characters than any other
show well enough to do that so I went my
little [ __ ] like IBM Selectric
because this was still before like
actual computers because I'm old thank
you and and wrote like 45 pages of an
episode of Star Trek where they brought
Kong back to to the to the enterprise
yeah because I'm a [ __ ] nerd of
course that's what I'm gonna do and I
sent there off just into the wild
because that's what you do you expect
nothing and then like three months later
I get a letter saying that I won this
competition which was [ __ ] bananas
you won the competition the grand prize
was we're gonna give you a like a $3,000
stipend to spend a month and a half in
Los Angeles working for boo productions
they were then in production on a show
called Brooklyn Bridge
what's his name Gary yeah and and a
second show to be determined later
so Mike alright [ __ ] I'm 19 years old
they're sending me to Los Angeles for a
summer before my senior year this is
amazing I can't believe this is
happening to me I moved to LA by myself
at 19 living on Hollywood Boulevard in
some like oakwoods apartments if it
doesn't even exist anymore should not
have been living on Hollywood Boulevard
in nineteen years old I didn't have a
car I couldn't really drive out here
because I'd have money to rent a car I
couldn't drink I drank but I wasn't
supposed to but every day was just I got
a bicycle and I rode my bike down Gower
to the lot and and live the dream for a
summer the show that was to be
determined ended up being Star Trek to
the next generation
it was the summer they were they were
shooting the pilot for Deep Space nine
so I got to not just like read scripts
for season 5 of next gen but it was
we're making a new Star Trek show the
like the first real spin-off of this
thing and we're starting to just like
field scripts and ideas and you got to
read scripts you got to sit around
pitches and and it was amazing it was it
was the most instructive like summer I
have ever had just getting to see how
you make TV from the inside and get to
talk to people to do it for a living
my biggest regret is that I did not stay
in Los Angeles like I went back home
because my dad was like you're not not
graduating from [ __ ] college I didn't
I didn't come all the way from a country
you can't even speak the language of to
not go to [ __ ] college it wasn't even
a discussion your dad came from France
but so I went back I got my college
degree I finished my education I took an
internship at Starlog magazine which
doesn't exist because magazines don't
exist Starlog and psycho pretty [ __ ]
cool it's not bad yeah thank Orias back
from the dead i also worked for Fangoria
and then started a career as a magazine
journalist but if I'd stayed like if I'd
stayed I would not have had to break
into television 20 years later like I
just would have been in I would have
gotten a job on Star Trek I would have
and that would have been it I might
never have graduated from college and
that might have been fine but I would
have been a working TV writer at twenty
years old and then the life that I have
now I would have had when I was in my
20s which probably not a good idea
because my twenties I would have made a
mess with this much money it's [ __ ]
nuts sorry to be gauche but they pay us
too much [ __ ] money to make [ __ ] up
I'll take it but still so so and it's
way to lose the audience mr. one person
how much money I was talking about being
rich but I made it poignant [ __ ] like
that yes you're like we writers were so
overpaid but but I I looked back on that
time and its glorious and wonderful and
and some of the context that made then
have still paid off but I would not have
the people in my life that I have now
had I not done what I did like I would
not have been a journalist for this long
I would not have met all these people
along the way we would not be podcasting
if I had not been the person who didn't
stay in Los Angeles and I said it went
back to the East Coast and and live the
life that apparently I was supposed to
have so it's it's a regret only in the
alike sliding doors serendipity version
of regret of the it's a thing I've
wanted since I was 19 because I tasted
it at 19 but it it feels better and is
worth more having gone the securest path
that I did to get there so all I would
say is reach for the thing that you want
when you can but don't be bitter when
life gives you a different road to
follow because you have no idea what's
at the end of that road and the journey
is more important than the destination
at the end of the day although the
destination is [ __ ] awesome so live
live your life to the best of your
ability live it as full as you possibly
can because nothing is guaranteed
tomorrow is a rumor and you know live
live for today and enjoy the [ __ ] out of
it so happy birthday happy birthday
I realized that came up short I didn't
never regret do you not really I mean
you know I guess I regret nothing
business-wise nothing professional but I
regret maybe not going vegan in my 20s
it really worked out like [ __ ] but I
never would have thought to do that back
then because the food wouldn't have been
edible back then when you were vegan you
literally ate vegetables I couldn't live
like that you know I got to eat
something that was a vegetable until
it's been crushed into something edible
yeah I don't really have a [ __ ] regret
I mean there's used to be a part of me
where I was like oh man I wish like I'd
written the role of Randall in clerks
for me to play that's why Randall has
all the best jokes and then as we got
close to production I was like I'm not
an actor why did I think I could play
this role I can't memorize all this [ __ ]
who wrote this dialogue and then I was I
was like well I'll cast somebody else
that was Jeff Anderson he crushed it and
but I was like you know if I'm gonna
make this movie I at least want to be in
it too and I've realized who Sound Bob
doesn't have to memorize any dialogue
and plus them to be yelling at Jay the
whole movie anyway so I'll stand next to
them and that's how that happened so as
much as I'm like oh man if I'd played
Randall who knows what kind of like
career I'd have like I might be an actor
today and [ __ ] but you know playing
Silent Bob like I think went a lot
further in some weird [ __ ] way like
we didn't intend those characters to
become what they became I've been living
off those characters for 25 [ __ ]
years I will probably live off them
until the day I [ __ ] die as long as
Jay has breath and as long as it could
be like supposed to the Nuge will be
standing on a street corner busking
somewhere so it wasn't the choice I
didn't write it for myself and I just
kind of backed into it I did choose it
as the director and stuff but you know I
can't even like argue with what happened
with that but you know everyone's a
while I'm like [ __ ] if I had played
Randall we'd be up to like clerks 19
right now
I'd have been in so many versions of
movies but yeah I mean one thing that I
always remind myself is that comparison
is the thief of joy say it again
comparison is the thief of joy the
minute you start to look to the left and
to the right and see what that guy has
when that lady does and whatever that is
you're not enjoying the life you have so
true so [ __ ] true and it's hard
business to not look over the fence
because sometimes you don't even have to
look over the fence there's a [ __ ]
billboard staring at you and [ __ ] like
that but it's true if you just focus on
you know to [ __ ] ameliorate and
generally you're much happier camper you
you will mature when you're supposed to
make sure we reach each of us is a
different kind of fruit and each of us
are gonna be ripe at a different time
and your time is your time my time is my
time it took me until 43 before I got to
do the thing that I thought I was born
to do that's what it takes it takes what
it takes
the important thing those you're asking
the question so you're already on the
path that's good most people you know
when they hit 30 aren't asking the
question so well then you win a boat sir
and you one poster in tickets do you not
want your birthday present you get the
poster in tickets no you don't get this
[ __ ] will you get that [ __ ] well done
all right JC we're we're gone now that I
feel so [ __ ] old hi guys how are you
hey what's your name you got move over a
little bit into the light sorry my name
is TJ give it up for DJ everybody sure
it's a an American video store American
video store yes sir it's a play I wrote
and directed that's premiering at the
Holiday Festival this this week oh yeah
so people could see it was it's called
an American video store Hollywood a
fringe door to buy tickets here's two
little postcard guys for you I don't
want to take up too much time no I just
saw the ad the banners for fringe fest
for those that don't follow or don't
live in Hollywood Hollywood for a few
years now has been doing the Fringe
Festival which is kind of they do it in
Scotland as well at Edinboro its
international yep they
they brought it over here and it's a
series of people doing plays and one
acts musical solo performances seminars
all different kinds of things 350 in
Hollywood this any note very nice thank
you I mean I know lots of folks come up
here and say you're the reason they came
out here and did this stuff I'm part of
that group I won't bore you with the
sentimentality but that's why I saw the
video stars like there's some connection
between us yeah that's about to call my
[ __ ] lawyer I'll tell you what rst
yeah so my question I'll try and keep
this brief it's a little bit complex but
I'll try and keep it brief so I'm a
studio exec I sit down and I say I love
fat men on Batman you guys have a great
chemistry you're both super talented
writers I want to give you a television
show right so I want to take advantage
of the strengths of both of you
Marc you did a great job with the show
on Hulu with a Stephen King universe you
you found all these unique ways to bring
that universe alive Castle Rock and I'm
sure there was multiple conversations
millions of in the writers room owned
like what approach to take because that
formula could have had a million
different outcomes but you picked one
that seemed to work right it got a
season to you want some awards
critically acclaimed it did some things
right Kevin the IP you have has been in
comic books and movies and cartoons and
video games it's a rich IP and it's all
about IPS these days right so the
question is and it's a little bit
complex I appreciate being patient with
me mark if you guys were to do a view
askew show right yes and I know you've
had variations as I'm sure with the
Mahler I show and things like that but
the question is mark not like you
pitching ideas on view askew and things
like that but what fundamental
foundational things about Castle Rock in
terms of bringing a universe to life
worked well and what would you pitch
totally because obviously it's a shift
to the view askew world from the Stephen
King world but what things would you
suggest to Kevin to take on to make that
show have an engine that worked as an
episodic television show I think Kevin
based on his suggestions
what would you then apply to your very
rich world to make the view askew
television show you're up first okay
let's switch places
there you go
I feel like my whole life has been
leading up to this mess get it writer
this is the last episode of Batman
Beyond ever
oh [ __ ] I'm thrown up I'd be on the
wrong side of the bar now I I think it's
some of it is deciding what the core of
that universe is and it's abundantly
clear that at this point is genuine I'm
Bob right so it's got to be a James
Helen Bob story I think you you have to
figure out a scenario to put Jay and
Silent Bob in that gives you longevity
and gives you an engine for that show
and and and what are they trying to
accomplish that takes a long time to do
I I kind of want to see Jay and Silent
Bob V the apocalypse and I kind of want
it to be like a robot apocalypse I don't
want it to be zombies
I think zombies zombies are too easy but
I think flummoxing Jay and Silent Bob by
a an overwhelming amount of robots that
don't even look like robots but I've
still killed everybody except for Jay
and Silent Bob and I having to do battle
with like grocery store robots just to
get food because most grocery stores are
kind of robotic anyway at this point
yeah i think i think it's Jay and Silent
Bob as two of the stewards for the
survival of mankind and is that mankind
if it's those two guys worth saving I
would never do that
[Applause]
let me think I do like the idea of them
in an apocalyptic world but [ __ ]
robots demons [ __ ] like [ __ ] raise
them from hell that way we just get to
do the golden child and I love yes
please give me give me the young tiger
what would I do
let me see what would I what would I do
if I was given like a view what could
tell a story that pulls all those
characters go well we just literally
number one we just did it with Jay and
Silent Bob reboot but to keep it going
on a regular basis to keep it like ten
episodes there's some fundamental thing
that Castle Rock did in terms of like
really uniquely taking a stab at that
universe that could be applied and a
little more abstract way than like let's
take the most to noticeable carriage
just throw them in like a hygiene kansui
adventure like disappointed by our idea
what Castle Rock did or tried to do was
distill what it means to be a Stephen
King story right and and what that means
it's got to be a small town members that
Town Hall needs to kind of know each
other
there needs to be some otherworldly
element at play that affects these
people's lives but but that is about the
vibe of what a Stephen King story feels
like and there's been so many of them we
can share numbers helps us distill down
and find the entry points that make the
most sense so I mean I feel like it's a
conversation then with kofte but I came
in what do you think is the the
distillation points of all of the view
askew movies what do you think is the
unifying themes what do you think is is
the necessary elements that need to be
in there I mean somebody needs to mean
Jersey clearly I've got a I go I got a
pitch alright crisis in infinite jerseys
so it is like I always felt there's two
versions of Jay and Silent Bob
there's the clerk's version of Jay and
Silent Bob and the Mallrats version of
James now Bob black and white and the
color version of Jane saw Bob those two
worlds suddenly noticed that they both
[ __ ] exist and they're one of them's
crashing and you have to do that one Jay
and Silent Bob exists in two realities
one in black and white reality one a
color reality only one reality is going
to make it through yeah that's pretty
cool that's pretty like Jim it's a
metaphor for like me letting go of the
past finally which I never will because
like Silent Bob black and white Silent
Bob will need to sacrifice himself from
the black and white universe and move to
the color universe and be the one black
and white character in that universe one
of them has to try get to live you
[ __ ] get to live but there has to be
sacrifice yes there has to be you know
somebody's got to do the thing that's
impossible to do the thing that's
impossible to do in a Kevin Smith movie
grossed more than 30 million dollars
that's the ultimate goal that or what
brings the entire universe together
somebody's guy who's somebody well
originally the plot for Jay and Silent
Bob strike back was a quick stop was
going to be closed and they went on a
journey to find the money to keep it
open and not because like Dante and
Randall originally didn't want it open
it was being closed and they were happy
about it like oh it's going away we
don't have to work here anymore
and Jay and Silent Bob were upset
because they have nowhere to stand so
they went out to find the money to save
Quickstop and stuff much too like the
you know children of Dante and Randall
at the end because like now we're
[ __ ] stuck here I wouldn't do that
but I also think like yoga hosers is
probably the cleanest look at what what
the Stephen King pillars are right
you've got two characters both of which
you know our friends but have some
tension you're in a place doing a job
they don't want to be
and then like weird [ __ ] happens to them
like that's that's what that story kind
of feels like and so what are the other
iterations of that story that we can
look at and if you're gonna do crisis on
infinite jerseys then like you've got
the girls you got black and white you
got color you got you know the two black
dudes who were in [ __ ] Harlem you got
the two guys working a bodega you got
like the the various permutations of
what convenience store life is like and
then one thing is threatening to destroy
them all and then they've got it
Alanis Morissette god is dead and then
the robots are making clerks you would
get your robots into this book it's like
a robot's man yeah man I don't know the
other thing would be to kill somebody
off yes so you tell the story that
brings them all together with the death
of one of them when we were making Jay
and Silent Bob strike back we were doing
videos it was Joey and Zack exact
Knutson who went on to make that
documentary about that was his name the
guy that wrote the Jaws speech
Milius wonderful doc and he just
directed super Khan movie about a heist
at a con Comic Con so Zack and Joey were
shooting our behind the scenes video
series which was called back to the well
it was for clerks too and at one point
they were like can we do a short where
you intimate like we accidentally show
off like a piece of something that if
you look real closely details that
Silent Bob dies and clerks too and I was
like oh my god that sounds fun let's do
it and so they we had storyboards laid
out and which is ridiculous we never
used two words for any of my movies but
one of the storyboards was like at a
rainy Cemetery and the [ __ ] tombstone
was shaped like Silent Bob and the plate
said forever silent
so we put the video up and sure enough
man and what would we do with the
decision was well put the video up let
it be up for an hour and then yank it
down and not say why and we did it and
nobody fell for it nobody [ __ ] left
work man all that preparation nobody was
like he dies but it would have been
worked it would have been worth it when
I worked at playboy we we did an April
Fool's Day joke which was there are
tunnels under the Playboy Mansion that
we're leading to like like Warren
Beatty's house and Jack Nicholson's
house and like there's there was a
secret network of like [ __ ] seventies
pervs who needed to be able to get to
the Playboy Mansion and without anybody
seeing them do whatever nasty [ __ ] they
were gonna do and then get back under
cover of darkness so like all right
that's gonna be area but Fool's Day joke
right right okay usually we have to do
we took a bunch of pictures of like
there's there's a basement there's a
wine cellar that they were rehabbing and
so he the story was when they were doing
construction at the mansion we found the
old blueprints and we mocked up the
[ __ ] blueprints and we had like video
footage of finding it and we dropped it
two days before April Fool's Day because
you can't just [ __ ] do an April
Fool's Day joke on April Fool's
everybody knows no it was like alright
two days before we're just gonna say oh
[ __ ] look what we found
and it made the news like it made like
[ __ ] like Fox 5 and like local LA
news like turtles under the Playboy
Mansion look at these old perverts and
like everything that had sealed it up
when he started having kids cuz they
want kids to get lost in the tunnels
right it's like so yeah it's just it's a
thing that doesn't exist anymore it
happened back in the day and and and it
worked it worked so well it was so
delicious he's the first my first pitch
was what if if was like a crime fighter
he's basically like Bruce Wayne but a
Bruce Wayne decided not to crime fine
not to fight crime but just like
actually drink and chase tail all the
time what if he was actually a [ __ ]
superhero what if he has a Batcave no
but what if there are tunnels that
sounds better than his robots idea I'll
tell you that yeah
that was a great question man you win
tickets on a poster my friend when this
when does it play the fringe fest one
more time yell it out Sunday through all
of June an American video store it's the
life and death of blockbusters and
Hollywood videos which I'm sure everyone
here has a very intimate relationship
with and Stephanie fury theater it's on
Melrose it's very close to here
Hollywood fringe George come come check
us out every poster grab that before we
go hey man so look at this got a gift
from the spod squad smart squad or the
cats that come to all the fat man on
Batman's they've gone out to Jay and
Silent Bob reboot as well and they made
it shirt and this is for me I get to
keep this does mark not get one I never
get one man just [ __ ] you
thank you for this man I'll [ __ ] wear
this next weekend [ __ ] when we when is
our next show by the way our next show
is the 18th of June 18th and that's not
next week not next week and then June
25th and then July 2nd fantastic
skipping a weekend in the next three
Tuesday's tickets as always available at
sea smart but that means we're the end
of tonight's show we got no more content
left
ladies and gentlemen have you had a good
time this evening don't forget when
you're heading out there's some stickers
that miles made for us all they're gonna
be available right here on the bar grab
those and whatnot yeah I grab some
already yeah I love anything with my
[ __ ] face on it man like I'm so
old-school and Biblical like I love
graven images of me so that's this is
right up my [ __ ] alley
and you look adorable I do we both have
pac-man eyes which I love as Dozen right
the the show laser gentleness as always
is made possible by a grant from the
MacArthur family no it's made possible
the Helena Rubinstein viewers legend and
viewers like you I was getting to that
point it is actually made possible by
viewers like you man this is still like
such a fun [ __ ] show to do it's so
chill it gets to be entertaining but
being entertaining doesn't seem to be
its main function and whatnot it's a
nice chill-out time when we could just
get to cigarette and sit around and
[ __ ] and it took me I [ __ ] red
hot minute to get here unfortunately me
as the [ __ ] Grateful Dead's playing
at the Hollywood Bowl holy [ __ ] traffic
was [ __ ] nasty and at one point when
I was driving I was a god [ __ ] damnit
but then I realized where I was going I
was like soon as I get there everything
will be alright and you know what it was
thank you for that ladies and gentlemen
but there is no fat man I'm Batman with
the guy without the man to my right
normally leads to my left give it up for
the great Mark Barnard and later on and
that is Batman Beyond for this week I'm
Kevin Smith I am mark Renault tune in
next time same bat time same bat Channel
SModcast comm slash Kevin Smith or
youtube.com slash giving some there it
is good night everybody look by your
feet grab the empty glassware let's
avoid a shattered disaster here thank
you so much next show is June 18th hang
out have a drink